[Music]
my name is stephanie dawson i'm the ceo
of a berlin startup science open
[Music]
so science open is a freely accessible
discovery environment
we contain um
at the moment uh over 72 million records
of research articles pre-prints books
and chapters
and we're
free for all researchers around the
globe to use
to
share
review
curate content on the site
and our business model is based on
providing services to publishers and
institutes um
to
promote
and
create and publish open access
journals um we have really a focus on
open peer review from the beginning open
peer review has been at the center of
what was driving science open so we
really open up those 72 million articles
to open review
and so we're also thinking a lot about
[Music]
how we can connect that
process to the other parts of the
scholarly infrastructure and how we can
provide
more visibility for open access research
both for researchers and
for publishers libraries and institutes
[Applause]
so open science describes a series
of research practices with the aim to
expand the principles of openness to the
entire research process
so
our open scientist
she might publish her hypothesis already
in a database online freely accessible
so everybody knows
what kind of question she's um working
on
then
she would use perhaps open notebook
systems um she would publish her data as
she works in um open data repositories
all completely accessible to the entire
community um she would get feedback from
colleagues during the entire process and
would feed that into
her analysis of the results the first
product of that analysis might be a
pre-print
um which is essentially looks like a
research paper but it's really early
stages um and that could be published
in a pre-print repository either at the
university or a subject repository like
bio archive or in the hard sciences
archive that
pre-print can then be openly discussed
um in a
in a open peer review um online
anywhere from twitter to
platforms that have been developed
specifically to peer review preprints
and
when she's finally ready through
revision to publish that
paper she would definitely publish it
open access with a creative commons
license a cc by 4.0
attribution license that says anybody
can use or change or work on these
results they just have to give her
credit
so the idea is that the open scientist
is always looking for
tools and
practices
in
the digital environment to get the
widest possible distribution
and impact for those research results
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
scientists have been
collaborating and sharing results
since the beginning of science so um
that's a
a standard scientific practice
what has turbo charged this process
is the internet
and the digital environment in which the
speed and
accuracy with which these results can be
shared
has
has grown
exponentially the pre-print server
archive was really the first in the hard
sciences physics math um there was
really a long tradition of researchers
sharing early results among themselves
as a manuscript that they called a
pre-print um
but really with the archive that started
in 1991
and was first really accessible via the
internet in 1993
that's when
that became a
standard part of sharing open
early
research results
[Music]
a former colleague and strong open
access advocate john tennant reminded us
every day in the science open office
that open science is just science done
right i think he personally had some
bumper stickers printed with that
and
the goal of open science would be really
to drop the open and have science just
um be much more collaborative
but
science is also a highly competitive
field so in this
in this highly competitive
environment
researchers are still measured on
the
the journal that they've
published their results in
how elite is it what's its impact factor
this is still the measure of scientific
success
and there's a lot of ways in which
researchers can endanger that success
by being open their data could be used
by other researchers if they publish too
early
the peer reviewers at the journal might
think this isn't very novel anymore it's
not that innovative so they could
potentially miss out on getting
published in a elite journal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i think what we saw with the pandemic
was really
we saw both a turbo charge of
digitization in the system and we saw
research really speeded up so everything
that the open science movement has been
promising that the open access movement
has been promising that freely
accessible
research a free exchange of data between
researchers that this would help solve
problems faster and i think we saw this
in real time when i
first
started a collection of uh covet 19
research uh on the platform there were
like 50 articles um i saw some
data
published in nature that estimates are
that roughly 200 000 articles were
published in 2020 on
um a
covid19
from lots of different perspectives
papers were published openly
as a preprint
online
they were reviewed on twitter on
review platforms
they were revised new versions were set
up and they were finally published in
other journals but before that already
that data had been shared with research
labs across the world and with the
general public so
um also uh journalists were
looking at um those pre-print servers to
see what's the newest what do we know
have we any idea of how we might be able
to treat this disease so
um there were lots of really
a lot of positives i think um that came
out of the
pandemic for open science
[Music]
the expert
does peer review themselves every day
all day long right they're always
evaluating research to see how good is
it how useful is it to me is it
something i can build upon if not
next paper
but for the general public
they look at all of these papers look
the same and you have no idea did an
expert say oh i can build on that or do
an expert say oh this method section is
totally useless
so
um in some ways this um
peer review process is
to a great extent for the scientific
record and for
the um
and the public very
very important um and i think we did see
journalists being careful and saying
this hasn't been peer reviewed that yet
this is early results um
but other journalists weren't so careful
um and
for the
general public i think we saw
some amount of
uncertainty
about
scientific results and the scientific
process in general which
this is how science has always worked
um
science is always saying oh
these results were wrong here's a a
better hypothesis
but um sometimes the public doesn't see
that the public is confronted with
something that's called a fact
and
their assumption is that this has been
generally accepted by the academic
community
[Music]
i think the answer is even more openness
so
the answer isn't going back to a black
box system
but the challenge
the challenge is to create a system that
is
really radically more open
and then to also
train the journalists and public on a
new system
and i think we have a
we have a system that worked wonderfully
in a paper age
we've been in a transition period
for the last um
20 years or so
but i think we really are ready to
move to a different kind of science
communication system
value different things
evaluate research differently
and i think we're going to need to train
the public and the media and
the um
political institutions um in order to
move towards a more
open uh
science
[Music]
you can see um with the fall of the wall
there's a huge symbolic weight in berlin
berlin really stands worldwide for
opening up
you know uh tearing down walls opening
things up so it's also very fitting that
there's the berlin declaration about
open access
um berlin has been at the forefront of
open access
since the beginning
and so for us
with so many universities in berlin with
a really lively research community in
berlin
with some other academic publishers in
berlin who've also been thinking about
open access
for us
it really made sense to
be located in berlin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you